Starbucks is in serious trouble and
we'll go through the case plus president
Trump reaches out to North Korea and
Democrats try to take Ted Cruz's seat in
Texas I'm Ben Shapiro this is Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
as always it is a busy news day and I
have a lot to talk about particularly
with regard to the Starbucks fiasco I
just hate how the media covered these
racial incidents without actually
waiting to hear all the facts without
waiting to see if there's any additional
evidence the immediate jump to
conclusions is pretty astonishing we'll
get to all of that in just a second
first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at quip so every single
day you are brushing your teeth I would
hope because otherwise you're a gross
person but when you brush your teeth are
you really using the best kind of
toothbrush to do so well you should be
using quip clip as the new electric
toothbrush that packs just the right
amount of vibration into a slimmer
design at the fraction of the cost of
bulkier traditional electric brushes and
guiding pulses actually alert you when
to switch sides making brushing the
right mount absolutely effortless quip
even comes with a mount that suctions
right to your mirror and unsticks to use
as a cover for hygienic travel anywhere
whether it's going in your gym bag
whether it's going in your carry-on and
because the thing that cleans your mouth
should also be clean quip subscription
service makes sure that you get a
refresh on your brush I'm a dentist
recommended schedule deliver a new brush
has every three months for just five
bucks including free shipping worldwide
so you're never gonna have to worry
about using a brush head that's eight
months old and still has your food from
four months in it
instead you have a new brush head every
three months and you never have to worry
about it because as soon as it arrives
in mail you just pop it on your
toothbrush and you're good to go
quip is backed by a network of over
10,000 dental professionals including
dentists hygienists and dental students
most toothbrushes don't get named one of
Time Magazine's best inventions of the
year equipped did and there's a reason
why equip starts just 25 bucks and if
you go to get quip comm slash Shapiro
right now yet your first refill pack
free with equip electric toothbrush
that's your first refill pack free at
get quip calm slash Shapiro GE t qu IP
comm slash Shapiro get quip comm slash
capiro and again use that slash appear
so they know we sent you and ensure that
you get your first refill pack
absolutely free with that quip electric
toothbrush get quip comm slash Shapiro
alright so I want to start today with
the situation over at Starbucks this has
now become a national issue so Starbucks
is supposed to shut down every one of
its stores for a day next week because
there was apparently an incident in
which two black guys were at a
Philadelphia Starbucks and sat down and
the manager asked them if they wanted to
buy anything and they said no and
according to them at this point she
called the police according to her they
continuously refused to leave they were
they were they were just loitering and
she called police the police came the
police
apparently ask these guys to leave the
guys refuse to over and over at which
point the police arrested them so
Starbucks has of course apologized for
the incident the woman in question has
not been fired she apparently no longer
works at the store which makes me a
little suspicious it does make me a
little suspicious it makes me a little
suspicious that startups didn't just
fire the lady if they actually thought
that there was a deeply racist incident
that had happened you would imagine that
they would get rid of the lady for
simple legal reasons having this woman
hanging around if she actually was
participant in a racial incident seems
like really stupid stupid policy but
Starbucks didn't get rid of her which
leads me to believe there might be a
little bit more to the story so today I
want to go through the media hubbub
about all of this and I want to ask a
few simple questions that are all
answerable this is not true the ring I'm
not saying I don't believe I don't
believe these guys story I'm just saying
that I want to see the evidence on all
sides and I don't think that that's
unreasonable so for example the the guys
go on Good Morning America the two black
fellows go on Good Morning America and
they are being given national coverage
for an incident in which they were
threatened with arrest for apparently
sitting in a Starbucks for no reason and
the tape was originally taken by a woman
that by a couple of different people who
are at the Starbucks a new claim that
they saw this racial incident unfold
when the guys asked to use the bathroom
they were told they couldn't use the
bathroom because they hadn't bought
anything and then they refused to buy
something and the manager whose name is
Holly apparently called the police for
loitering so here is a little bit of the
of the ABC News exclusive interview with
these two guys now again I have to point
out that this is being wildly overblown
okay the lady is presumably being
punished the the Starbucks has
apologized they're shutting down their
entire entire company for a day to teach
about implicit bias I'll discuss
implicit bias and how stupid implicit
bias assessment tests are in just a
second and why implicit bias training is
completely useless from a social science
perspective I'll talk about that in just
a few minutes here but important to note
Kyle Smith has a good point national
review there are two hundred and
thirty-eight thousand employees of
Starbucks let's assume that everything
that said here is right let's assume
that this this manager this this manager
at the Starbucks was a brutal horrible
Bull Connor type racist would that
implicate everyone who works for
Starbucks Kyle Smith points out two
hundred thirty eight thousand people's
like the entire population of the city
of Richmond if someone killed somebody
in the city of Richmond would you say
listen I'm never traveling to Richmond
again I'm to boycott Richmond would you
force the entire population of Richmond
to go and get implicit bias training or
just say that's a bad person alright so
first of all this is an individual issue
at the very most and second of all we're
not even sure if it's an individual
issue yet because as I'm gonna point out
there are cameras in the store like this
is an amazing thing I'm amazed nobody's
asked this before I've been asking this
for the last couple of days every
Starbucks I've ever been in has cameras
they have cameras there because they
want to ensure that if a crime actually
does take place on the premises that
they can hand that tape over to the
police so I asked my listeners to
actually go over to the Starbucks I has
one particular listener who had been to
the Starbucks knew the manager said that
this manager was a social justice
warrior leftist who is so woke that she
spends her days telling people not to
use the wrong pronouns and yet this one
is supposed to be the great racist in
the whole story she still has not
publicly revealed herself or told her
side of the story but in any case I
asked a couple of my listeners and one
of them one of my Twitter followers if
they could go take a look at the
Starbucks itself to see if there a bunch
of cameras there it turns out that from
the picture she took there are no less
than four cameras in the establishment
and yet we have seen no camera tape from
any of this the only reason I'm breaking
this down this way folks is because it's
a national story otherwise I wouldn't
care because when the I'll give you an
example there is a story from Applebee's
there was an there's an Applebee's as I
believe that it was in Wisconsin and
just back in February I was Missouri
rather appellees fired three employees
in a Missouri mall based restaurant back
in February that a determined were
involved in the racial profiling of two
African American customers whom they
falsely accused of skipping out without
paying their bill the restaurant chain
also apologized for the February ninth
incident at the Independence Missouri
eatery the apology comes after one of
the diners Alexis Britton posted a video
of her encounter with employees from her
cell phone and commented on the incident
on Facebook the restaurant the
independent center mall was temporarily
closed and the video showed up a
restaurant staffer a police officer and
a security guard talking to two woman
one of whom was crying uncontrollably
had been estimated viewed three million
times the company said that it regretted
the incident and the manager the server
and another employee were fired hey this
is a quiet visit an incident where I'm
not questioning what happened because
the company fired the employees the
company not only admitted what had
happened the company then fired the
employees and apparently this is a much
more clear-cut case where the police
were called on these particular women
were accused of walking out on their
bill but they did not walk out without
paying their bill they actually were
trying to pay their bill right according
to the Facebook post about an hour into
dinner these two women were accused of
ordering food the day before and leaving
without paying their bill then and then
it turns out that these were not the
same two women so the employees were
fired yes that's an easy one to prove
right there's the receipt their evidence
that they were there the day before or
they weren't there the day before right
it turns out the employees were all
wrong and they were all fired so in that
particular case I'm not saying show me
the tape in this particular case I'm
saying show me the tape because there's
a little bit of countervailing evidence
and you're gonna see the countervailing
evidence here so I'm gonna play you the
account of the two men who are on Good
Morning America again this is now
national incident even though it's at
best one person at a Starbucks in
Philadelphia important to point out that
this was manager Holly she's working at
a Starbucks in Philadelphia Philadelphia
is 42 percent black if you really think
that Holly has not dealt for the past
year with any black customers or that
she's a wild racist who's discriminate
against black customers it's weird that
everything was fine for a year in a 42%
black city were presumably a lot of the
customers are black and again as I say
one of my listeners I talked about this
yesterday on the program one of my
listeners knows Holly has been there and
has seen her deal with black customers
and has never seen any inkling of
anything like this but all right here's
the account of the two men on Good
Morning America an I'm gonna show you
this even conflicts with the police
accounting of what happened I want to
show you also how the media treats it so
Robin Roberts is the one doing the
interview on ABC News's Good Morning
America I hear it is dontay you both
walk in you get a table
rashon how long was it before you asked
to use the restroom immediately as soon
as I walked in and she stated that they
were for paying customers only what
happened next
we're at the table we said now we're
just talking amongst each other
she didn't comes from around the
register as you know walks up to us
you know she can help us with anything
can you start with some drinks or water
or something like that you know when we
have bottles of water with us so you
know we're fine we're just waiting for a
meeting we'll be out really quick it's
like thing according to 9-1-1 accounts
a call was placed at 437 approximately
two minutes after you arrived to 9-1-1
what did you think when you saw police
arrived Dante you can't be here for us
okay so what's posit there from one
second so first thing to note here is
when she says that they arrived at 4:35
and then the call happened at 4:37 how
does she know what time they got there
right I mean she she's not revealing how
she knows that because presumably she'd
either have to have testimony from
Starbucks itself she'd have to have
access to tape she'd have to have
witnesses who said 4:35 or these guys
told her they got there at 4:35 and in
437 this woman made a call we just don't
know the answer now this is one of the
areas where tape could obviously clear
this up you can see them walk in there'd
be a time stamp on the tape you know
whether this is true or not according to
the police this is not what happened
right if you actually listen to what the
police officer said right it's not it
doesn't match up with what these two
guys are saying so these two guys are
saying that they walked in they sat down
they asked to use the restroom
they were declined because they did not
buy anything they were asked if they
wanted to buy anything and then they
refused to leave because they're waiting
for somebody okay that's that's their
story now here is the police officers
story so here is that here's the police
chief in in Philadelphia who is black
and he is telling the story of what
happened according to the police when
the call was initially made is Starbucks
employees they told the male's that they
were going to call police and they said
go ahead and call police we don't care
so police get there and they're
confronted by the same type of attitude
and repeatedly they're told that they're
not leaving in fact there is some
alleged rhetoric about you don't know
what you're doing you're only a $45,000
year employee or something to that
regard and so because these individuals
refused to leave because Starbucks
actually called the police did not just
happen upon this event it is not just
walk into Starbucks to get coffee they
were called there for a service and that
service had to do with bullying of the
service of disturbance that had to do
with trespassing so I need to underscore
the fact that these males were arrested
when they were arrested they were taken
out essentially without incident there
was no harm done to them but after being
transported to the police district in
the area the officers at the processing
paperwork discovered that Starbucks know
longer was interested in Christ okay so
listen to the police and what the police
chief says is when they arrived they
asked these men do you want to leave me
I said no we're not leaving and
apparently at one point they said we
don't care go ahead and arrest us okay
this is not the same story the media are
telling right the media are telling a
story where these two guys walk in there
are no trouble at all they're just
sitting there and then they're arrested
for no reason after being incredibly
polite to police officers the police
themselves are saying that's not what
happened we don't have the story of
Holly the manager there many of the tape
footage reg in there four cameras in the
establishment from what I can see from
these pictures that are being sent
publicly on social media and there's
been confirmed by a couple of people and
yet the media are running this as though
this is a bull connor Jim Crow story I'm
gonna explain in a second why this
really isn't even that but first I want
to say first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at filter by so what
is the last time you check the filters
in your central air system it's one of
these annoying kicked the can down the
road habits well here's the problem
you're not only aggravating your health
you might be destroying your HVAC system
leading to thousands of bucks and
repairs so stop procrastinating visit my
friends and filter by America's leading
provider of HVAC filters for homes and
small businesses they carry over six
hundred different filter sizes even
custom ones all shipped free within 24
hours plus they're manufactured right
here in the United States filter by
offers a multitude of any RV options all
the way up to hospital grade check your
system specification so you can pick the
right option and maximize efficiency and
elevate the quality of the air that you
breathe set up auto delivery and you're
never gonna need to think about air
filters again did you show up at your
house and you save five percent save
money save time breathe better
filter by com filter bu why.com there's
a reason that we use filter by at the
Shapiro household there's a reason that
we're using it here at the daily wire
offices when we need fresh air filter by
is the place to go filter Bui comm again
that is filtered by dot-com and again
when you when you use filter by comm you
can set up auto delivery and they will
deliver these things regularly plus you
save 5% on the deal so filter Bui comm
filter by com okay so let's discuss for
a second why Starbucks has this policy
about loitering in the first place so
this is the impression here is that
Starbucks employee just decides randomly
these two black guys got to go don't
like them they're black okay that's the
story that we're being told on national
television by Good Morning America again
facts being stated without any real
verification again Robin Roberts saying
there's a two minute delay between the
time these guys sat down and the time
the police were called you know again we
don't
no like I don't know where that's coming
from because what you'll see is that the
media will report it saying things like
these two men arrived at 4:35 and then
by 437 the police were called or let's
say it has been reported has been by
whom by whom okay
again I don't want to break this thing
down like this approver tape I don't
think it's that important and instant
but the media think it's that important
an incident where we wouldn't be talking
about this if the medium weren't blowing
this up into all of America is
implicitly racist including Starbucks
right this is what this is all about
again I wasn't questioning the
Applebee's incident that happened back
in February because that was an actual
racial incident and the people involved
were fired by the train which apologized
okay so obviously and and
again the reason that I asked for
substantiating evidence is because we've
had too many cases in the past of
high-profile incidents like this where
it's turned out that the whole story was
not being told I remember Michael
Bennett who's a football player last
year claimed that the Las Vegas police
department had cracked down on him for
racial reasons and then the tape came
out and it turned out the reason they
cracked down on him is because he was
acting in criminal fashion and so if
tape is available I like tape this tape
is not available we have to evaluate the
evidence of the people who are talking
but just as in a police incident I want
to see the body cam footage before I
make any sort of judgement in this
particular incident I don't think it's
unreasonable for Starbucks to release
footage of exactly what happened here
now there are a lot of people who say
well Starbucks won't release the footage
because they know that they're guilty
okay it's also possible Starbucks won't
release the footage because they know
that if they release the footage then
the entire media and the black lives
matter movement would suggest that they
don't care enough about racism and
they're fighting back against these
charges because they're racist
themselves this is the way the racial
game is played unfortunately which is if
you provide countervailing evidence to
the charge that you are racist then the
media will claim that you are even more
of a racist because you're not
acknowledging your white privilege and
people's different sensory experiences
okay but here's the point Starbucks does
have this policy for a very long time
okay Starbucks has had this policy with
regard to people not using the bathroom
for a long time and they've had
controversies about this policy for a
very long time and in just a second I'm
going to bring you that controversy i'ma
show you that controversy okay so here
is the story there's another Starbucks
in Philadelphia at 13th and chestnut
streets it sent to me by another one of
the Ben Shapiro show listeners hey in
the and this is from NBC Philadelphia
calm okay this this story is dated
September 15th too
fifteen in the wake of a social media
post that went viral over the weekend
claiming a Starbucks barista tonight in
a uniform Philadelphia Police Sergeant
access to a restroom at a downtown
Philadelphia coffee shop Starbucks has
apologized to the sergeant the
spokesperson for the International
coffee shop chain told NBC 10 the
company personally apologized to the
police sergeant for the incident which
happened late last week the sergeant
according to a Facebook post shared
thousands of times walked into the
Starbucks at 13th and chestnut streets
and asked for the key code to use the
restroom an employee according to the
post stated in a loud voice that the
bathroom is for paying customers only
the post went on to say the sergeant
politely requested access again and the
Starbucks employee continued to deny it
loudly as customers listened while she
continued loudly to tell me about the
bathroom down the street I was even more
astonished that the many customers
another employee said nothing in seemed
indifferent this is the world cops live
in anymore wrote the sergeant who has
declined to comment saying he didn't
anticipate his post would gain such
traction officer Joe lightheart a friend
of the sergeant was one of the first to
share the fellow officers post about the
incident Lainhart says he personally has
been in that Starbucks location several
times on calls for service but never as
a customer I didn't intend for it to go
viral lightheart said as adding that
most people who have responded to the
post have been supportive Starbucks
wrote in part quote we are aware of the
situation it is certainly not in line
with the experience we want any of our
customers to have in our stores we are
taking all necessary steps to ensure
this doesn't happen in the future
this officer apparently was white that
there's no indicator that the officer
was actually black and so the idea that
you know the loitering policy is being
exclusively used on black people
again I'm not seeing all of the evidence
for this but the entire point here is to
shake down Starbucks the entire point is
to make the entire chain filled they're
responsible for the actions of one
employee even without us even knowing
the whole story about the employee
so now Starbucks is going to be getting
implicit bias training to all of its
employees this is deeply stupid implicit
bias training is a giant giant giant
waste of time Hillary Clinton back
during the 2017 campaign talked about
how implicit bias was a problem for
everyone not just police and she said
that too many people jumped to
conclusions about each other of course
senator Cory Booker has talked about
implicit bias
okay people tend to use what they call
the implicit association test as proof
of implicit bias
okay the implicit association test is a
test that you've probably had if you're
on a college campus where some idiot
sociology professor says we're going to
show that you we're going to show you
you're racist you don't think you're
racist you've never done anything racist
but secretly
like Freudian unconscious secretly
you're actually a racist I'm a way that
we can tell this is what we do is we
show you a black face with some words
associated with it in a white face with
some words associated with it if you
more quickly identify white faces
associated with good words than black
faces associated with good words this
means that implicitly you're racist now
there are a bunch of problems there are
a bunch of problems with the IAT the
studies are not particularly reliable
they have a relatively small sample size
they find no significant correlation
between implicit bias and behavior in
the real world Texas A&M psychologist
professor Hart Blanton points out that
scores on the IAT mean virtually nothing
quote there's not a single study showing
that above and below that cutoff people
differ in anyway based on that score
social psychologist Russell Fazzio of
Ohio State University says quote as
traditionally implemented the IAT really
has problems even advocates of the IAT
like its creator professor Anthony
Greenwald admit that these findings are
simply not appropriate for settings such
as courtrooms
in fact one major study has found that
quote being alerted to potential bias
and limited response control through
direct personal experience such as that
provided by the IAT can lead to worse
rather than better behavioral regulation
statistics show the correlation between
IAT and political preference are
stronger than racial preference and
there's good evidence to suggest that
the IAT measures in-group out-group
implicit bias rather than racial bias
per se so if you're told which people
are which group is your group you
associate good things with that group
off the bat jesse single of New York
magazine or Jessie I'm friendly with
Jesse Jesse is not on the right jesse is
a definitely liberal guys left guy he
says that the fact that the idea that
the IAT predicts behavior in any serious
way is not true he says a pile of
scholarly work some of it published in
top psychology journals and most of it
ignored by the media suggests that the
IAT falls far short of the quality
control standards normally expected of
psychological instruments the IAT is a
noisy unreliable measure that correlates
far too weakly with any real world will
outcomes to be used to predict
individuals behavior and by the way
implicit bias training does nothing
either right single points out both
critics and proponents of the IAT now
agree that the statistical evidence is
simply too lacking for the test to be
used to predict individual behavior and
so we're now being told that if you
train people on implicit bias that this
is going to fix things again the data
just is not here ok the data is just not
here but nobody needs the data this is
all just an attempt to again paint the
as broadly racist because of one
incident that is still under controversy
and for which we have not seen tape and
if you ask for evidence then people call
you racist because that's the way this
works now it's just it's it's just
ridiculous I got questions from the
media for asking for tape I asked for
taping people why are you asking for
tape for the same reason the US per tape
when a black guy gets shot by a cop
because you want to see what happened I
mean why is this even a question okay
and it's just a second I'm gonna talk
about president Trump's at foreign
policy some foreign policy achievements
may be in the offing despite media
coverage to the contrary first I want to
say thanks to our sponsors over a policy
genius so 71% of people say they need
life insurance only 59% to people
however have coverage that means at
least 12% of people are procrastinating
and you know sure normally
procrastinating is a bad thing but if
you die it's a really bad thing if you
don't have life insurance in fact
there's a guy who a friend of mine new
online just a couple of days ago who
dropped out of a heart attack didn't
have life insurance serious problem for
his family this is why you need to go to
policy genius calm so policy genius is
the easy way to compare life insurance
online you can compare quotes in just
five minutes it's really really easy can
be sitting there watching TV and you can
compare quotes while listening to this
podcast policy genius has helped over 4
million people shop for insurance place
over 20 billion dollars in coverage and
they don't just make life insurance easy
they also compare disability insurance
renter's insurance health insurance if
you care about it they cover it so if
you need life insurance but you've been
putting it off because it's too
confusing or you don't have the time
checkout policy genius it's the easy way
to compare top insurers and find the
best value for you there's no sales
pressure zero hassle and it's free
policy genius.com when it's this easy to
compare life insurance there's no reason
to put it off policy genius.com do it
now before you die because you
afterwards can be too late policy
genius.com go check it out okay so while
all of this hubbub on idiotic social
issues continues to plague the United
States actual things are happening in
terms of foreign policy so it's really
interesting there really is no Trump
doctrine as of yet we don't know what
the Trump doctrine is there have been a
few attempts to define president Trump's
foreign policy the real truth is that
President Trump's foreign policy is ad
hoc he's basically making decisions on
the spot now what's interesting about
this is that I think that most
presidents actually are doing foreign
policy on the basis of ad hoc foreign
policy I don't think most of them sit
there with a formula I don't think they
sit there with an abacus I don't think
they sit there with an algebraic formula
with different variables and they input
different countries and different
numbers in and this
concludes whether they ought to use
diplomacy where they ought to use the
CIA or whether they ought to use
military strikes I don't think that's
how it works I think foreign policy is
generally a matter of muddling through
for the United States and it has been
since World War two President Trump
makes that obviously clear because the
muddling is so clear in just in public
right I mean every so often the
president just reverses himself on a
matter of foreign policy whereas
previous administrations have tried to
lay out a coherent reason why they're
doing what they're doing and sometimes
that coherent reason is just not
coherent Trump doesn't even bother right
Trump is obviously just kind of lurching
side-to-side I don't think that that's a
change in kind I think that it's just a
change in the way that that is presented
to the world now sometimes that ends
well and sometimes it's kind of weird
right so in in one case right now
there's obviously some controversy about
what exactly President Trump is gonna do
with regard in North Korea so yesterday
President Trump was doing a press
conference with Japan and he said that
we've had talks with North Korea
high-level talks have been taking place
with the North Koreans but we have had
talks with the highest okay so we'll
have to see how this plays out a lot of
people are very skeptical of the idea
that any serious negotiation can take
place with the North Koreans I'm one of
those people who's skeptical because
again I think that the North Koreans
have no interest in giving up their
nuclear program I think this is another
shakedown effort the North Korean
government has for the last 35 years
been routinely firing missiles doing
nuclear tests doing all this stuff in an
effort to pry goodies out of the United
States and out of our allies they did it
under Clinton they did it under Bush
they did it under Obama and now they're
doing it under President Trump so I
think it's a little premature to
celebrate the the fact that we are
talking with the North Koreans is some
sort of grand design to to change the
face of North Korea however it is
important to note that the New York
Times is reporting today that North
Korea is now removing a major obstacle
to us negotiations according to South
Korea so it is important to note here
also by the way that South Korea's
government is what they call a sunshine
government meaning that they have
attempted to ratchet down tensions with
the North Koreans and any possible cost
according to the New York Times kim
jeong-hoon North Korea's leader has
removed a key obstacle to negotiations
with Washington by no longer demanding
that American troops be removed from
South Korea as a condition for
denuclearizing his country according to
the South's president moon jae-in okay
this is actually pretty important
because if it is true that North Korea
is not to manning the United States
withdraw troops from South Korea from
the Korean Peninsula then a deal is much
more in the offing the United States was
never going to withdraw troops from
South Korea no matter how much President
Trump might want to do so simply because
we have strategic interest not only in
South Korea but in the Korean Peninsula
and the South China Sea more broadly so
removing our troops from North Korea of
herrmann from South Korea was never a
thing the change in stance according to
The Times
if officially confirmed by the north
could affect the United States long term
military plans in Northeast Asia and
ease Washington's reluctance to strike a
deal North Korea for decades the
reclusive country an ally of China has
persistently demanded the withdrawal of
two 28,500 American troops in South
Korea citing their presence as a pretext
to justify its development of nuclear
weapons that a man has always been a
non-starter for South Korean and
American negotiators on Thursday mr.
moon said North Korea no longer included
that to man in list of things that
wanted in return for giving up nuclear
weapons that has encouraged the United
States to proceed with plans to hold its
first-ever summit meeting with North
Korea so one of the serious questions is
what are they going to ask the United
States to give up and the bigger
question is how are we going to verify
that they have indeed given things up
remember in 1994 the United States
signed on to a North Korean nuclear
framework agreement that President
Clinton claimed was going to end the
North Korean nuclear program involved
the United States giving the the North
Koreans a light water nuclear reactors
that they could have domestic nuclear
energy and also involved assigning major
checks to the North Koreans it was
impossible to verify and obviously now
North Korea has nuclear weapons it'll be
interesting to see if the North Koreans
think they can play the United States
this way again one of the major issues
when it comes to negotiations of North
Korea is whichever party is in power has
an interesting claiming that their deal
is gonna work we see this with the Iran
deal right the Iran deal is a giant fail
but the Democrats still have an interest
in claiming that it worked the Syrian
deal where we were told that Russia was
going to remove all chemical weapons
from Syria we were told this was a
massive success by everyone on the Left
including the New York Times up until
the point when Assad started gassing his
citizens again at which point everybody
had to recognize that it was a failure
every administration and all of their
backers have an interest in claiming
that every negotiated deal that is cut
is a success but without significant
teeth to the actual verification regime
all of these promises mean very very
little
the moon the North Koreans did not
present any conditions that the United
States could not accept such as the
withdrawal of American troops in South
Korea they only talk about hostilities
against their country and about getting
security guarantees it's safe to say the
plans were dialogue between North in the
United States could proceed because that
has been made clear so we don't really
have a clear plan from the United States
as to what we are going to demand in
terms of verification standards North
Korea in 2016 demanded the u.s. stopped
deploying long-range bomber submarines
and other nuclear strike capabilities in
and around South Korea but you know it
is unclear that the United States is
actually going to is actually gonna do
any of those things so we'll find out
what happens here but there's very
little question that this is you know
somewhat ad hoc or I mean this is all ad
hoc foreign policy and again I'm not
blaming Trump for that but it does
create a certain amount of confusion in
terms of world politics creating another
amount of confusion is the Trump
administration approach to Russia so
earlier this week obviously there were
promises that Russian sanctions were on
the way after Russia helped sponsor
Syria's governmental chemical attacks on
civilians in in Syria nikki Haley went
on national television she claimed that
we were gonna put in sanctions on Russia
and then Larry Kudlow came out and said
we're not putting sanctions on Russia
well now Trump is defending himself he
says there's no one who's been tougher
on Russia than I have been there's been
nobody tougher on Russia than President
Donald Trump between building up the
military between creating tremendous
vast amounts of oil we raised billions
and billions of dollars extra in NATO we
had a very very severe we were talking
about it a little while fight in Syria
recently a month ago between our troops
and Russian troops and that's very sad
okay so this is this is all true I mean
what Trump is saying here is true the
problem is when you have conflicting
messages coming from President Trump
obscures the fact that in some of these
areas particularly on Russia the policy
has been pretty harsh so it is the open
chaos of the administration that's a
problem for the administration not the
actual policy and this has long been
true right as Kanye West would put it
and did yesterday on Twitter distraction
is the opposite of vision to a chat
respondent actually guac home as the
opposite of vision but in any case the
idea that that the administration is
being very distracting about how it
pursues its goals is certainly part of
the problem now a lot of that is not on
administration obviously the media have
an interest in providing distractions
because the economy is doing quite well
under President Trump because there are
no foreign major foreign crises under
President Trump they have to make it
seem as though there's a greater amount
of cast in the administration even than
Trump is creating and to that end
they've continually promoted James Comey
and they keep pushing call me all right
they keep saying that James Comey the
former FBI director has something
important to tell us and then he gets on
TV and he has nothing important to tell
us it's a real irritant it's a real
irritant because every time I see him on
TV I just assume there's nothing
important for him to tell us because he
doesn't have anything it's just the
media pushing him so yesterday they were
pushing him again and James Comey came
out and I'm not sure why this is any
sort of news he says I'm not a
Republican anymore James Comey says he's
no longer a Republican yeah shock of
shocks in your heart of hearts do you
still consider yourself a Republican no
no the Republican Party has left me and
many others
I need no better evidence than their new
website which i think is lyin Comey may
be attacking me I just think they've
lost their way and I can't be associated
with it well I guess the dad that's
that's the end I mean this this guy is
the the master of loyalty we've been
told that this is a duty loyalty guy I
mean if James Comey can't be Republican
who can be a Republican or maybe James
Comey is angry at President Trump
doesn't like President Trump listen I
didn't vote for President Trump in 2016
I don't like a lot of things about
President Trump I am still a Republican
and I'm not gonna give up the Republican
Party to people I disagree with simply
because I want to take my ball and go
home
again they keep trying to claim that
James Comey is some sort of you know
grand arbiter of decency here I'm gonna
show you in a second why none of this is
news but first we're gonna have to go
over to Daily wire comm for $9.99 a
month you can get a subscription to
daily we're calm when you do you get the
rest of this show live Andrew Clavin
show live Michael Knowles's show live we
have new goodies that are coming just in
a couple of weeks here actually so now's
a good time to subscribe plus if you get
the annual subscription then you get
this the very greatest in all beverage
vessels the leftist tears hot or cold
daily wire tumblr for 99 dollars a year
which is cheaper than your monthly
subscription you too can become a member
of the ben shapiro show cadre and you
will enjoy every moment of it plus if
you just want to listen later for free
go over to itunes go over to youtube
please subscribe please leave us a
review we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
so why is james comey in the news the
answer is that he shouldn't be I mean he
doesn't have anything new to say how do
I know this because even James Comey is
now acknowledging that he doesn't think
that Donald Trump is gonna fire Robert
Muller
well if he doesn't think the Trump is
gonna fire Robert no remember the entire
reason James Comey is in the news right
now is because James Comey and his
allies in the media have been suggesting
the president Trump engaged in
obstruction of justice and he fired
James Comey in order to shut down the
Russia investigation well if you were
trying to shut down the Russian
investigation presumably James Comey
would be saying well you know it's
really nice edge right now president
Trump's gonna fire Muller it's just
gonna show more obstruction but James
Comey can't even say that because at
least he's honest enough to admit this
he says I don't think Trump's gonna fire
Muller okay so then why are we talking
about firing the guy who's investigating
him that doesn't look a lot like
obstruction to me but here's gonna call
me admitting it what if they hate fires
Muller were you gonna be with the guys I
don't think that's gonna happen and I I
don't because it would make no sense for
a bunch of reasons
okay so again I mean DEA would make no
sense for a bunch of reasons and like
he's admitting that he has nothing
newsworthy to say here the only thing
that's newsworthy about and about James
Comey is that now he's in a fight with
Andrew McCabe right so it turns out that
Andrew McCabe who's his former deputy
was there was an inspector general
report suggesting that he had gone
without commis permission and talked to
the media and mccabe is saying listen I
asked James Comey and James Comey was
fine with all this okay so that means
that it's now Macomb it's a Comey McCabe
fight yeah all of this is making the FBI
look bad it's I'm making Trump look much
worse than he already looked but it is
amazing the media continue to trot him
out put him on major shows like the view
and the only person on the view who asks
him any tough questions is of course
Megan McCain Megan McCain did a really
good job grilling him the other day here
she was going after James Comey I think
that maybe j edgar Hoover is rolling
over in his grave at saying the types of
things are saying and revealing
types of things you're revealing it
doesn't seem like something and the
director of the FBI why are you laughing
it really he's the wrong
he didn't tell all when he left yeah so
yeah okay so it's you know she's exactly
right here but again the media have an
interest in promoting stories that are
that are more scandal about Trump this
is this is their thing it's the reason
they continue to push the the stupid and
idiotic claims about Sean Hannity and
Michael Kohn I remember Sean Hannity
turns out to have been a client of
Michael Cohen Cohen was of course
Trump's lawyer and the media are making
this into a major issue even though it's
not a major issue Andrew McCarthy over
at national view has a long piece today
about why it's idiotic that Hannah Dee's
name was even revealed in open court
like what exactly does Sean Hannity have
to do with anything
and yet the media have been running with
this story is though it's a major story
because distraction is the name of the
game it's so funny the media accused
Donald Trump of distracting with one
hand put the shiny object over here and
then pursuing policies they don't like
over here well there's one problem
that's exactly what the media are doing
right now we're pursuing a nuclear deal
with the North Koreans right now we are
pushing on the economy right now we are
discussing very controversial measures
with regard to Syria and trade and yet
all of our focus is going into James
Comey and Michael Kohn and look how the
media are just out of their minds and
and excited and just jazzed about the
sean hannity news which is a big nothing
burger it's a giant nothing burger that
sean hannity used michael cone as his
lawyer or didn't use michael collins in
the wire who cares who cares me michael
collins in legal jeopardy no matter what
here so i don't know what tron hannity
has to do with anything but it doesn't
matter the media are going to a
particularly CNN MSNBC of course are
gonna use this as an opportunity to club
fox news here's the anderson cooper
doing just that
in the two days that have elapsed since
the president's lawyer michael cohen was
forced to reveal in court that the
mystery client he tried to keep secret
was in fact sean hannity the
consequences have been swift and his
employer fox news did what any
respectable news organization would do
and faced with the knowledge that one of
its anchors had gone on the air time
after time after time to breathlessly
report on someone without disclosing his
own personal connection to the story i'm
kidding
they don't care they don't care because
CNN you know they but they've always
disclosed personal connections of all
the people working at CNN to various
democratic politicians like always and
then they're very good about this MSNBC
did the same thing right they're
suggesting that fox news is actually
running
the administration of the United States
which is insipid but again none of this
has to do with anything real but all of
it does generate numbers and generates
controversy the newness memo was a huge
ratings boon for Fox what Donald Trump
ended up doing - Christopher ray his
hand-picked director of the FBI was
among disgraces the most disgraceful
thing he has done for Christopher ray
went to Paul Ryan and said please for
the love of God don't release the
newness memo it's incomplete it's
inaccurate it brings into question one
of the most sacred processes we have the
secret FISA Court shot and this is why I
think we get this wrong foxes in
state-run media the state is run by fox
Sean Hannity needed that story and I
think he ran the president like an asset
the way people are wondering if the
Russians are running the press yes Sean
Hannity is running President Trump as an
asset yeah this is the real news thank
you for your news coverage guys and then
we're supposed to pretend that this is
news cut just just ridiculous okay so
meanwhile is any of this having any
impact on the polls well the evidence
tends to show no so the so the polls are
not as good for Democrats as you would
assume that they would be so right now
the smart money is on Democrats still
taking the house but there's a series of
new polls that don't seem to be going
all that well for Democrats so according
to Julie Kelly over at the Federalist
the tide seems favorable for Democrats
as a record number of incumbent
Republicans including the Speaker of the
House are not running for re-election
but less than 7 months out a strong
undercurrent is pulling the blue wave
out to political see a trove of new
polling shows the ones formidable lead
Democrats had in the generic
congressional ballot is nearly gone
wedge issues such as gun control and
immigration are not working in Democrats
favor in fact thanks to trump even
independent voters believe democrats are
using the children of illegal immigrants
for political purposes rather than
legitimately protecting their wealth or
i think that might be to pro-trump point
for me but let's look at the polls in
Washington post/abc News poll released
on Monday voter preference in the
November election shows a four-point
lead for Democrats 47 percent to 43
percent among registered voters
that's a drastic drop from a 13-point
advantage Democrats had blown out at the
end of last year there is no enthusiasm
gap for Democrats Republicans are now
more more motivated to vote than
Democrats in November 86% of Republicans
say they're absolutely or certain to
vote this fall compared to 81% of
Democrats Democrats only hold the
six-point lead among independents and
among the 18 to 39 voters so that poll
is not particularly good and NBC
news/wall Street Journal poll indicates
Wayne
support for Democrats as well the
respondent skewed Democrat by a
seven-point margin which was the exact
level of preference for a Democratic
Congress at forty seven percent to forty
percent the polls showed a big drop in
the percentage of voters who want
Democrats to win in order to keep tabs
on Trump and the GOP in 2000 docto burr
2017 a number was 46% today it's only
40% now are all the polls good for
Republicans no there's a very bad poll
today for Ted Cruz you know senator Cruz
who you know you would think would
cruise to reelection no pun intended in
Texas is apparently not according to a
nuclear pact University poll that poll
shows that Cruz and beta O'Rourke who's
a representative from Texas Democrat
it's a very competitive race now they're
saying that 47% of registered voters in
Texas support Cruz 44% back O'Rourke
that's a three point six percent margin
of error for the poll and president
Trump was apparently underwater in Texas
with 52 percent of respondents
disapproving of him and 43 percent
approving of his job performance Cruz's
favorability rating shows a pretty
polarized response 46 percent of Texans
have a favorable view of the senator 44
percent have an unfavorable view Cruz
has been trying to fight the perception
that he is either anti Trump or Pro
Trump from two various sides right and
the people who are Pro Trump claimed
that Cruz can never be forgiven for the
fact that during the RNC in 2016 he
didn't overtly endorse President Trump
then people who are anti Trump claim
that Ted Cruz has bent over for
president Trump in a variety of ways
including today he apparently wrote a
profile for a president from for the
time 100 the most important 100 people
in the country when Cruz wrote the
profile of Trump which is pretty glowing
a lot of people are saying well why
would he do that it just looks
politically motivated in any case the
the polls are too over the place to
declare exactly where this is going to
end up which is of course why Democrats
are going to try to cheat or at least
one Democrat is going to try and cheat
Andrew Cuomo in New York has now
declared that parolees can vote is an
amazing thing so by executive order
Andrew Cuomo the governor of New York
declared that now people who are on
parole can vote okay so you would ask
how can he possibly do this legally
wouldn't that require a law well the
answer is yes it would require a law and
the legislature in New York which is
still run by Republicans says no you're
not going to pass that law so Andrew
Cuomo just says I'm gonna make sure that
36,000 people who are on parole can now
vote the reason for this of course is
because he figures all of those people
will vote for him
in primaries and in a general election
now imagine if there a dictator of
another country who simply declared that
all political prisoners who he was now
releasing were going to be able to vote
for him we would say well that seems
kind of corrupt Andrew Cuomo went ahead
and did that in New York and no one
seems to care no one seems to care so
we're told the Republicans in Joe Biden
two days ago said Republicans are trying
to suppress voter turnout they're
hurting to keep black people from voting
he has no evidence of this whatsoever
none zero zip zilch IDs for voting is
not voter suppression when Republicans
say however that maybe Democrats want to
let illegal immigrants into the country
because they want to legalize those
immigrants and then have them vote for
Democrats that looks a little better
that statement was a little more true
today given the fact that Andrew Cuomo
just unilaterally declared that 36,000
people in his state could vote who are
on parole the whole reason by the way
you're on parole is because we don't
trust you to be fully reintegrated back
into society which is the reason we
don't allow you to vote generally if
you're on parole
so again just corruption and corruption
well done New York Andrew Cuomo the
worst one of the worst governors in in
the country okay so time for a couple of
things I like and then a couple of
things that I hate so the things that I
like today so I've been watching the
series of the expense so I've
recommended the books of the expanse
before by by James sa Corey I think
that's his name but now there is a
there's a series of it on sci-fi and the
series is quite good it starts slow by
the end of season one at the beginning
of season two it gets really good it is
pretty significantly different from the
books which I've found interesting I
think it's better than the books in a
variety of ways the plotting on TV
generally is better than the plotting in
books because you can waste a lot of
time in books they can't waste on TV
anyway here's a little bit the preview
for season 1 of the expanse
may I ask you something you miss earth
these endless blue skies
Freire everywhere and open water all the
way to the horizon when you spend your
whole life living under a dome even the
idea of an ocean is almost impossible to
imagine they are an entire culture
working together to turn a lifeless walk
into a garden we had a garden and we
paved it someday things gonna change
okay so the series is actually quite
good and it is from the writers of
children of men and Ironman so it's it's
got good credentials it looks really
good too I mean for a cable series that
looks really tremendous so check out the
expanse you can see it I believe on
Amazon Prime Amazon Prime by the way now
has a hundred million members well dams
on Crimea everybody's whining about
these big companies Amazon Prime makes
my life a hell of a lot better it
probably makes your life a hell of a lot
better too this is why when President
Trump rips on Amazon Prime I'm so
annoyed by it I get any movie I want at
the touch of a button okay that's
amazing that's amazing
I can order any product anywhere at any
time right I'm just sitting around and I
remember that I forgot to pick something
up from the grocery store I just order
it Amazon Prime is just unbelievable
love it okay other things that I like
today so Laura engrams ratings actually
spiked after all of the controversy over
David hog remember there's a ridiculous
call to boycott Laura Ingraham because
she tweeted out that David hog was
whining about his college admissions and
then David hog said well let's boycott
them so two things one David hog now has
called for a boycott of Vanguard as in
the investment fund because they invest
in a couple of gun manufacturers they
have a six billion dollar capitalization
six billion okay anything that you try
to boycott from Vanguard is gonna be a
rounding error it's just a giant fail
it's strategically idiotic but in any
case it turns out that the boycott on
Ingram was also strategically foolish
because all of her ratings have spiked
so according to the hill in the three
months before the advertiser boycott
Frenzy Ingram averaged two point five
million viewers per night consistently
winning her 10:00 p.m. timeslot then the
advertiser controversy got going and
Ingram went on what FNC was a planned
vacation since Ingram's return a week
ago the show's viewership has jumped to
three million viewers per night more
than her average before the controversy
erupted just demonstrating once again
that in the real world when you generate
controversy for a show more people tend
to watch it rather than fewer people
particularly if the controversy isn't
about something supreme
you awful that somebody said which was
the case obviously with it with laura
ingraham okay time for a couple of
things that I hate so speaking of the
the Parkland survivor's Time magazine
again in their 100 most important people
they have now put the powerful in
survivors but not all of them obviously
my friend Kyle cash of the 16 year old
student over at Parkland he is not
included in the time 100 of important
people it's only the ones they've
already seen Cameron Cassie and Gonzalez
and David Hogg
those ones are all in there and who
wrote the profile of them who else but
Barack Obama no I'm not kidding you
wonder about media bias having the
former President of the United States
where the glowing profile a bunch of
seventeen year old because he agrees
with their agenda that might be a little
bit of media bias I remember that a
couple years ago I think was Malala
yousufzai whose profile was written by
Hillary Clinton K Time magazine is doing
that to promote democratic policies and
Democratic politicians well you suicides
an amazing person I have no idea why
Hillary Clinton should have been writing
her profile yeah another thing that's
kind of ridiculous is that apparently
David and Lauren hog right the sister
and brother they've now signed a book
deal with Random House in the end that
book is going to be called hash tag
never again a new generation draws the
line talking about all the things that
they've been attempting to do find that
they have a book deal all right I mean
that's good for them I mean they want
they had them on a write book that's
fine they say they're gonna donate some
of the proceeds to charity
good for them my problem is the title of
the book okay never again is about the
Holocaust okay the the phrase never
again came about after the murder of six
million Jews systematically by
governments okay the idea that you're
going to equate an evil shooter who
killed 17 people and the crisis that
that presents for American society more
importantly that that crisis is going to
be equated with the Holocaust is just
insipid it's Justin's hip and the fact
that nobody over at Random House thought
hey maybe we shouldn't compare this to
Holocaust is really quite absurd it's
really quite absurd on on every level
one final thing that I hate so
apparently there's a new documents been
brought to light according to a
Breitbart by James des Morris
class-action lawsuit James d'amour
you'll recall he's been on the program
he was the guy who was fired from Google
for putting out a memo trying to explain
a couple of reasons why there may be
fewer women than male engineers over at
Google apparently there's a document
that was brought to light that was
drafted by the company's HR department
instructing managers of the company on
how to be inclusive and it cautioned
managers again
rewarding employees for trades quote
valued by the u.s. white male dominant
culture okay what exactly were they
supposed to be worried about apparently
they were supposed to be worried about
meritocracy winning avoiding conflict a
belief in objectivity a colorblind
racial frame urgency numbers driven and
perfectionism right these are these are
the values that are valued by white male
dominant culture because that's just
terrible how could we I mean just
terrible but here's what we really need
to do we need to listen raise up vote
voices identify multiple viable paths
everything's a work in progress
sustainability okay if you run a company
on the basis of the non apparently white
male dominant cultural features your
company's gonna fail if you're not
running a company based on a meritocracy
winning avoiding conflict a belief in
objectivity you're going to fail your
company is going to suck okay and if
Google actually ran on the principles it
says it runs on rather than the
principles it says it hates then Google
would be bankrupt as well but it just
goes to show how much social justice
narratives now come to dominate the way
that that so many of these major
companies run their business okay we'll
be back here tomorrow with all the
latest i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Plummer executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is austin stevens
edited by alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018